sabin abrió un nuevo gimnasio de artes
marciales sea en lte la ganancia neta
del gimnasio por supuesto medido en
miles de pesos después de 'the meses es
minúscula y en es mayúscula la función
esta gráfica da abajo y en efecto aquí
tenemos la gráfica de las ganancias
después de meses de que abrió el
gimnasio muy bien dice la siguiente
tabla contiene proposiciones verdaderas
en pareja cada proposición con la
característica de la gráfica que mejor
le corresponda y aquí tenemos estas
características de la gráfica por
ejemplo máximo mínimo relativo intervalo
creciente o decreciente y aquí tenemos
proposiciones o afirmaciones que ai qing
digamos emparejar con estas para saber
si son una adecuada interpretación de
estas características y ahora podemos
ver podemos ver o podemos interno
podemos ir viendo más o menos cómo es la
gráfica
al iniciar el gimnasio parece ser que
hubo una ganancia de 4 estaba estaba
medida en miles de pesos y no mal
recuerdo exactamente en miles de pesos
tenemos una ganancia de 4 mil pesos pero
después por alguna razón el gimnasio
empieza a perder dinero incluso verdad
empieza a perder dinero y luego se
empieza a recuperar a lo mejor hizo
alguna buena estrategia de venta a quién
sabe y empieza a ganar mucho después más
allá de 13 meses empieza a ganar mucho
más
ok entonces vamos a emparejar estas
características con su interpretación
así que si por ejemplo buscamos la
característica del máximo mínimo
relativo en realidad aquí tenemos un
mínimo verdad más o menos por ahí de de
6 cuando t es igual a 66 meses y el
mínimo es más o menos de menos menos 3
mil pesos verdad o menos 3 pero como
está medido en miles de pesos sería
menos tres mil muy bien entonces aquí
podemos ver que en realidad hay una
si tenemos una ganancia negativa que
quiere decir que hay una perdida así que
por ejemplo aquí está la proposición de
hecho ya estaba emparejada bien verdad
las ganancias netas del gimnasio
estuvieron en su mínimo a los seis meses
y eso es justamente lo que podemos
observar vamos a ver ahora dice
intervalo positivo o negativo entonces
podemos ver que el intervalo negativo es
justamente de 2 a 10 meses verdad eso
quiere decir que entre los dos primeros
meses y los diez primeros meses de bueno
entre el segundo mes y el décimo mes que
estuvo abierto el gimnasio hubo pérdidas
hubo pérdidas ok
mientras que de 10 en adelante y del
digamos desde que abrió hasta el segundo
mes hubo ganancias vamos a ver dice aquí
las pérdidas del gimnasio superaron a
sus ingresos entre los 2 y 10 meses
posteriores a la apertura es justamente
el intervalo negativo así que
corresponde a esta interpretación y
ahora vamos a ver que en f
estos dos digamos se corresponden bien
el intervalo creciente o decreciente
dice el el digna el perdón el gimnasio
pérdida dinero los primeros seis meses
muy bien eso quiere decir que
que en efecto el gimnasio durante los
primeros seis meses iba teniendo cada
vez menos ganancia es verdad entonces
iba perdiendo dinero así que eso es una
buena interpretación de dicha
característica y es correcto